[Musique]
elle est pas belle et sacripant sont les
amis des enfants vers l'hypothèse et
sacripant sont des gens charmants sol
sacré penche en avant mais pas toujours
pas un enfant envoient leurs messages
pour voir si tu es sage séduit les
chances et seulement du long
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les petits enfants sages bonjour
les amis
quel dommage que vous l'ayez pas j'étais
là hier soir qu'elle ce mardi
silence-lotto rigoler riz sacripant riz
au point que j'en ai encore mal votre
wii depuis mai face car on peut dire que
le pauvre lucullus du on est retourné il
madame l'hypothèque nous sommes et
branques leur guise
coutts après pas comment veux tu que nos
petits amis s'y retrouve
le mieux serait de commencer par le
commencement en indiens sikhs uriane
signerait pas possible à la don dès que
le palmarès a été terminé nous nous
sommes précipités dans la cuisine et
j'ai ouvert le gros cahier de madame
lipopette à la page bonnes grosses
sommes j'avais mis un gros tablier
j'attends de pied ferme
j'ai commencé la lecture et peluches et
des carottes
abbas que j'ai fait illico des poireaux
des navets un loignon du céleri tout ça
je me faisais le mieux possible
jeter le tout dans une grande bassine
remplie d'eau nous y sommes mis à deux
pour la porte et hyper lipopette à
allumer le feu j'ai repris mon livre sel
poivre pas de problème
un gros os à moelle flac ajouté un
bouquet garni avant de refermer le
couvert alors là les choses ont commencé
à se gâter
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un bouquet garni
n'en savait rien ben non alors j'ai
envoyé sacripant chez le fleuriste
je suis revenu avec un joli bouquet de
fleurs nous l'avons portée dans l'eau
bouillante
c'était bien dommage si vous aviez mis
la tête devant la bimbo pas quand elle a
dissout lever le coude à a
j'ai cru qu'elle allait s'évanouir
haha sommes pas sérieux en haut tu as
raison tu vois tu me fais tous être en
retard au palmarès aller vite vite vite
tourner la manivelle avec cuisine il n'y
a pas que nous de dissiper aujourd'hui
un coût mais ce n'est pas très grave
hu est en effet allé le cocotier
notre voyage commence à panazol dans la
haute-vienne et c'est une petite fille
qui ouvre le palmarès aux prénoms
commencent à percer comme clients non
non non non non il s'appelle cécile
bailly 21 rue du 11 novembre 1918 87 350
panazol c'est une gentille petite fille
de 2 ans et demi qui aime beaucoup notre
émission elle la trouve même trop courte
oui hélas beaucoup de chagrin quand elle
le voit disparaître de l'écran
bien sûr mais nous aussi nous aimerions
bien être avec vous tout le temps enfin
il faut penser il faut penser aux
grandes personnes ne soient qui
regardent la télévision et qui ont
besoin de se distraire aussi et dans la
journée il ya l'école et le soir il faut
aller se coucher
alors on ne peut pas être là tout le
temps de toute façon voilà comme tu es
une gentille enfants goethe inscrire
votre enfant dans une petite ville qui a
un très joli nom fontaine dans l'isère
et nous rencontrons une petite fille et
un petit garçon
l'apprenant que vaut ce
c'est comme sophie eric commandité par
ces non juste trompé des savons et ben
non c'est pas ça tu vois il s'appelle
sophie emmanuelle ena 15 rue jean
prévost 38,6 en fontaine et sofia 4 ans
et une petite fille qui travaille très
bien à l'école
tout le monde a l'air content de ces
résultats et puis elle est très gentille
et manu et les plus petits il a trois
ans alors il est à la crèche
mais il est très très sage ils ont une
petite soeur qui restent à la maison
avec leur maman us aux antilles oui oui
je vois les inscrits fait un million par
bizanos dans les basses pyrénées et nous
avons la joie de rencontrer un petit
garçon comme patrick donc enfin se
trouver c'est bien patrick gassion 64
320 maillon par bizanos il a deux ans et
demi si sa grande soeur l'euro ce qui
nous a écrit elle trouve qu'il mérite
d'être inscrit au palmarès car il est
très gentil et très mignon il adore
jouer au ballon
aouidat moi aussi c'est un mélomane il
écoute les disques avec ravissement
eh bien je l'inscris ce charmant petit
garçon né dans la région parisien à
gonesse dans le val d'oise
nous avons un enfant sage c'est une
petite fille
on fait nom commence par un comme
anémone
non non c'est pas ça c'est pas ça non
elle s'appelle angélique du mont houy
ranger 45 square des sports 95500
gonesse
hélas trois ans angélique va à la
maternelle pour la première fois tu vas
être ravis tu auras des petits camarades
et la maîtresse renseignera des tas de
choses comme le dessin la danse et le
chant en fin de toutes choses
formidables
elle ne mange pas à table mais par
contre elle aime tellement les bonbons
qu'elles risquent d'aller chez le
dentiste si elle ne fait pas attention
bref on va vers un effort ma petite
angélique 1 il faut absolument manger à
table
tu me le promets oui oui oui bon bientôt
je l'inscris sacre hip hop est à trouver
un enfant sage à thuir dans les pyrénées
orientales
oui cette fois c'est un petit garçon qui
a été sage
x comme xavier saviez oui c'est ça vous
aviez garcia hlm les halle berry ce
bâtiment c'est numéro 23 66 3 sentir
il a deux ans il regarde dans notre
émission sans remuer le petit doigt
alors c'est mignot ça c'est mignon mais
il n'est pas très sage et il ne mange
pas toujours à table alors que dois je
faire
mais sa crypte est a dû se tromper non
monsieur sacre hip hop elle ne peut pas
se tromper tout simplement vous aviez a
besoin d'être encouragé
et c'est pour cela qu'il a été choisi
donc je l'inscris en espérant qu'il fera
des efforts pour devenir plus
raisonnable ou exo rue pts au menu donc
c'est un drôle de nom ça ouais ouais
exemple et dans les vosges et nous avons
nous à vous deux enfants sages pour
finir le palmarès et deux garçons leurs
prénoms commencent par h et f
oh mais l'envergure et il s'agit en
effet de hervé et frédéric petitdemange
88,4 soho grand route
ils sont très gentils ils aiment
beaucoup les animaux surtout les
écureuils et il les trouve très beau je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec michel
m'étonne pas mais ne soit pas trop
orgueilleux je vous promets d'être plus
modeste à la wii mais revenons à nos
petits amis qui sont gentilles et sage
alors on peut les inscrire très bien
voilà qui est fait et maintenant le
grand moment est arrivé
hervé frédéric petitdemange de bezons
rue javier garcia de thuir angélique du
monde connaît patrick gaccio de meillon
par bizanos
sophie emmanuelle hainard de fontaine
cécile bailly de panazol
allez vite faire votre part un préposé
des ptt vous y attend pour vous remettre
colis plein de jouets comme ceci dit
étant maintenant d'aller manger quand la
soupe
bonsoir bonsoir
[Musique]